Today,
we're going to take up a question and it has been for the past,
well nearly 20 years,
probably the most active
to many of the most stimulating aspect of civil war scholarship.
How did the civil war affects civilians?
What were the social impacts of such a massive experience?
How could you mobilize societies on this scale
without profoundly changing people?
What did it do to gender relation?
What did it do with the meaning of race?
We've already begun to deal with that question is some in some depth how this
war would transform the constitution transform American political culture
transformed the lives of African Americans and more on that in time,
but of course social history one,
the revolution in American history,
oh,
somewhere back in the 70s and eighties everybody wanted to be a social
historian.
When I arrived at Amherst college circa 1989 to teach,
there was something in the,
what was known as the Pioneer Valley of the five college consortium,
a social history working group,
and I remember asking,
can you give a paper if it's not social history?
And the answer was sure.
Social History one sort of methodological struggle over how to do history.
What is the meaning of the past and you all know that by now whether you think
about it that much or not.
Social history brought us the history of women.
It brought us a revolution in scholarship in the study of African Americans.
It brought us a revolution in the study of class.
It taught us how to study social groups in historical time.
It's taught us how to study ordinary people
and then I'll get off of this historic graphical high horse.
It's remarkable how much civil war historians focused as they were so much on an
event focused so much as they were so often for generations.
As many put it on headquarters,
the headquarters of generals and a thousand's of dispatchers they wrote because
those were the sources or the headquarters of the government.
The president
commander of the army's focus so much on an event from headquarters.
A social historian came along in 1989 he wrote a brow is relatively short little
essay and the Journal of American history that became the title essay of a book
of essays.
It came out of your later,
it was by Maris vin off Skus,
a numbers crunching,
hard boiled social historian who use star og if you can't count it in history.
He wrote a little less,
they said,
have social historians lost the civil war is answering course was yes,
and he showed very carefully by looking at a few New England towns,
that old tradition of studying in Microcosm New England towns,
which colonial American here's had been doing for a generation or two.
He showed that there are all these towns all over New England,
small and relatively large.
There's a lost half of their men between the ages of 18 and 45 and four years of
war
and went to some local records and he discovered some of those towns have lost
60% of their male population.
Hmm.
He looked a little closer and he saw that the whole idea of occupations in those
towns get completely redefined,
at least during the war years because the men were all gone.
Okay.
You started to count widow and count orphans and by God you could count these
things.
You could measure how many widows were there in Newburyport,
Massachusetts,
how many widows were there in Bangor,
Maine.
You could count it.
It stimulated a small revolution in scholarship and it runs on a Beta as we
speak and in some ways the most important kind of history done on it.
There's two kinds.
It's the kind of new women's history.
You're reading a drew Faust book,
mothers of Invention,
wonderful title.
I don't know if any of you remember the old song by that title.
The fourth thing and about,
there's an irony in there somewhere.
At any rate,
you get a book like drew foes,
which stands on the shoulders of other books like it,
but a book that went and read thousands of women,
southern women's letters and diaries to try to understand how did this war
affects southern white women
and she has many answers to that,
including the somewhat bold argument at the end of that book that it was women
in part,
an argument has been tested by other scholars and and even backed off from a bit
by drew herself.
But she ends the book,
at least with this suggestion that the sheer weight of the burdens of the war on
southern white women and the thousands upon thousands of letters were in which
they express that to their mates,
their husbands,
their brothers,
their sons at the front,
okay.
That it was in part southern white women that made south give up the war.
Any other part of that social ministry revolution has been,
of course among military historians themselves who discovered ways,
the ways it always been there.
And there were pioneering works on this as early as the 1950s by a scholar
named,
um,
Bell Wiley who wrote two thick volumes,
one in 1954 or 55,
one entitled Billy Yank and the other entitled Johnny Reb.
And Lo and behold,
what that was,
is the beginning of a tradition of studying the common soldier,
his experiences,
his terrors,
his horrors,
his stomach problems is dysentery.
His disease is death and above all influenced greatly by the field of psychology
and influenced greatly by the rise of gender history.
Okay.
Male military historians went to those common soldiers and began to study their
values,
their idea,
their sense of manhood,
their sense of the idea of courage and what that meant.
And the 1860s and a mid Victorian society like the United States and one nuts
set of values by which men,
young and old,
defined themselves as men,
collided with modern total war.
What did it do to them?
And of course they being the male military historians of the 1980s nineties were
themselves greatly affected by the experience of the Vietnam War.
Now would that little bit in mind,
let me suggest something that is timeless about this question of the social
impact of war.
And then I'll get on to the substance of how the war affected southern society,
northern society.
The like
is there excerpts from letters from a soldier in Iraq?
His name is Juan Campos.
They're actually emails.
One was 27 years old.
He wrote this to his wife on December 12th,
2006.
Hey,
beautiful.
While we were on blackout again,
we lost yet some more soldiers.
Uh,
can't wait to get out of this place and returned to you where I belong.
I don't know how much more of this place I can take.
I try to be hard and brave for my guys,
but I don't know how long I can keep up.
Excuse me.
You know,
it's like every time we go out,
anytime bump or sounds freak me out.
Maybe I'm just stressing.
Oh,
hopefully it'll get over.
You know,
you never think that anything is or can happen to you.
At first you feel invincible and then a little by little things start to wear on
you.
That letter goes on and on ends of course would tell his eight year old son,
hello,
Tuesday,
October three,
2006 mood gloomy.
The life of an intern tree men is never safe.
How do I know I live in every day?
I lost a good friend of mine just two days ago to an enemy sniper.
The worst feeling in the world is having lost one of your own and not being able
to fight back.
The more I go on patrol or more alert,
I tend to be a,
regardless of the situation here in Iraq,
is that we are never safe.
No matter the counter measures we take to prevent any attacks,
they seem to seep through the crimes every day of soldiers lost or wounded by
enemy attacks.
I for one,
would like to make it home to my family one day.
Pray for us,
keep us in your thoughts for an infantry man's life is never safe.
December 15 2006 my only goals are to make it out of this place alive and return
to you guys and make you as happy as I can.
Sergeant compost was killed in the spring of 2007 by an eye.
You d.
This is a letter from the front.
Uh,
Charles Heard Charles Brewster dated May 15th,
1864.
There's a timelessness to what soldiers right from war and there's a
timelessness to its social impact.
Brewster's you may remember me telling you,
was that soldier from Massachusetts,
lonely and confused,
feeling worthless.
Join the Union army and the 10th of Massachusetts in April of 1861 and served
out the entire war,
managed to survive.
I wrote 260 quite incredible letters.
This is the middle of the Spotsylvania campaign,
arguably the worst constant daily trench warfare of the civil war.
He's the adjutant of his regimen and therefore he has to record all of the
casualties
sergeant compos describing in his war,
sort of worn a day.
But this was war that was killing people by the dozens.
He sends his latest report.
Uh,
our regimen suffered terribly in the fight the other day,
losing six officers wounded in eight men killed,
but 34 wounded that we know of besides probably a good many that we do not know
of.
And from 12 to 20 taken prisoners,
this makes a grand total of 13 officers killed and wounded and 24 men killed 135
146 missing,
making 218 officers and men in 12 days.
The regimen is reduced to 150 muskets.
At this rate.
There will be none of us left to ever see Richmond.
Their regimen would,
by the way,
within about a week and a half of that be mustered out cause they had
insufficient men to serve.
But he ends this letter with what he describes as the most terrible side he ever
saw were encamped on a splendid plantation and the corn and the wheat is growing
finally or rather was before we came,
but I am afraid the crops will be very small this year down here we have not
seen our wagons since we started and I'm getting sadly dilapidated.
My rears entirely unprotected.
I have worn the seat of my pants and drawers entirely off.
Most terrible side I ever saw was the rebel side of the breast work we fought
over the other day.
There was one point on the ridge where the storm of bullets never seized for 24
hours and the dead were piled and heaps upon heaps and the wounded men were
intermixed with the dead held fast by their dead companions who fell upon them
continually adding to the ghastly pile of men.
The breast works.
We're on the edge of a heavy oak woods and large trees,
18 inches or more in diameter were worn and cut completely off by the storm of
bullets and fell upon the dead and wounded rebels.
Those that lay upon our side in the night when the trees fell said that they're
howling were awful when these trees came down upon them.
When I looked over in the morning,
there was one rebel sat up praying at the top of his lungs and others were
jibberish and insanity.
Others were groaning and whining at the greatest rate all during the whole of
it.
I did not hear one of our wounded men make any fuss other than once in a while.
One would sing out,
oh when he was hit,
but it is a terrible,
terrible,
terrible three terribles business to make the best of this.
Oh,
it doesn't really matter what war you're talking about.
Charlie Brewster's descriptions could have been along the psalm and World War
One.
They could have been somewhere in the battle of the bulge of the Second World
War.
They could have come from donning and he could have come from the north of
Baghdad,
as it always says,
or near by zero or outside.
Mozel.
So what is tragedy?
What is tragedy in relation to war?
How do we understand tragedy through this prism of the social impact of war?
I think you only ultimately really do understand it by leaving headquarters,
by leaving the generals dispatches,
by leaving even Abraham Lincoln's magnificent pros and turn to see it through
ordinary I ordinary women,
ordinary men,
tragedies.
One of those words that we especially Americans tend to use haphazardly.
It's a pet peeve of mine,
but it's probably just my problem.
Um,
every plane crash is a tragedy.
A car accident is a tragedy.
We stub our toes and we call it tragic.
A tragedy is something we ought to see through the book of job.
We ought to see it through Shakespeare's character.
We ought to see it.
We ought to go back at least as far as your [inaudible] and the Trojan women.
What does Hecuba doing in the Trojan women,
but sit in a ghastly scene of an utterly destroyed city.
All of her men are dead and she sits whaling to the sky on a stone crying.
How can this be?
That's tragedy.
We should see tragedy through Hecuba are all those women and drew Faust book.
Okay.
Tragedy can be raw.
It can be pointless.
It can be utterly unbearable.
It can be a dead end with no exit.
Sometimes it is just seemingly faded horror,
but sometimes tragedy throughout its literary history and therefore how we tend
to use it.
Tragedy can also be affirmative.
It can even be Cathartic and we sometimes can find ways to make it redemptive.
Okay?
It should never be treated with triumphalism.
It requires certain mood.
Rebecca Harding Davis,
a wonderful American writer who experienced the war,
left us this coin,
amazing little description of what I would call a a simple picture
of tragedy.
She was in a tiny Pennsylvania town,
doesn't have a name.
It is 1864 and she describes a scene she witnessed at a train station.
I quote her,
nobody was insight but a poor thin country girl and a faded Calico gown and
sunbonnet.
She's still alone on the platform waiting.
The child was playing beside her.
When we stopped,
the men took out from a freight car.
Davis was on the train for give me
the men,
took out from a freight car,
are rough on plain pine box and laid it down,
burying their heads for a moment.
Then the train steamed away.
She sat down on the ground and put her arms around the box and leaned her head
on it.
The child,
when I'm playing,
we don't know her name.
We don't even know what town.
Between 1862 and 1863 life insurance policies in America doubled,
or the purchase of life insurance policies doubled
between 1861 in 1865 only two books were published in the United States on
anything resembling the idea of the afterlife during the war as utterly consumed
as Americans became with death.
They weren't writing yet about heaven.
Between 1865 and 1876 no less than 80 books were published on the idea of
afterlife of a heaven.
Americans as never before.
We're trying to invent a heaven
and the best selling book in the United States in 1868 and it was for a few
years after.
It was a book by Elizabeth Phelps called the gates of jar.
It's bizarre,
but fascinating book about what heaven actually is and what it looks like and
what you do when you get there and the compartments it has and the rooms that
has and who you'll see,
especially all those dead soldiers.
Gates a jar was a massive bestseller,
rival uncle Tom's cabin,
at least for the first time.
You
all right,
I'm gonna leave you there for the moment.
And one should never use the New York Times.
The first draft of history is historical source,
but I just did it.
So anyway,
um,
gosh,
yeah,
the civil war as social history,
while the people who really,
really started this of course were Charles and Mary Beard,
uh,
writing back in the 1920s.
It was Charles and Mary Beard and their economic interpretation of this,
or in their famous book,
their big book,
the rise of American civilization who said this,
and this is the challenge.
In some ways to all those who would refocus from the event itself onto the
social process or under ordinary people experiencing the event.
The civil war,
the beards road I quote,
was a social war.
Okay.
Ending in the unquestioned establishment of a new power in the government,
making vast changes in the arrangement of classes and the accumulation and
distribution of wealth.
In the course of industrial development,
the war was a social cataclysm in which the capitalist laborers and farmers of
the north and west drove from power in the national government,
the planting aristocracy of the south.
That's a fairly clear interpretation or judgment
the beards went on.
Then in the next paragraph actually to call it the second American revolution,
and I quote,
beard in a strict sense,
he,
they said the first American revolution,
the beards revolution and the civil war was a social economic revolution
and they made an elaborate argument for how this war transformed the economy,
transformed the nature of the government and transformed forever the
relationship of labor and capital,
but was the civil war ultimately a victory for big business over the agrarian
south?
It's been a question we've debated over and over and over and over.
We stopped debating it for quite a while.
Frankly,
that debate seemed like an old fossil when I was in graduate school.
Nobody wanted to be a beardie in anymore.
We were all going to be cultural social historian,
but it's very interesting how the debate has come back.
Okay.
Was the civil war largely a clash of economic forces?
Dustin Dover with one four so either you know,
free labor or slave labor going to overwhelm the other,
the beards and the rise of American civilization and it's 500 odd pages.
Almost never mentioned the word slavery.
Yeah,
to the beards economic forces where these inanimate forces in the world,
they kind of operated on their own.
It wasn't that much human agency.
Okay.
Did the civil war explode industrial growth or did it actually slow it?
You can get arguments on both sides.
The best research now shows us that the war itself was not necessarily the
single most important engine of America's great industrial expansion or the
birth of the American industrial revolution.
Well,
plenty of scholarship.
Now that shows us that that revolution is much older than the civil war,
that the real launching pad of American industrialization or the launching
period,
if you want to find it,
you got to go back at least to the 1830s and probably the 1820s
you can begin to measure this
GNP in the United States,
which I guess we called GDP now,
don't wait.
Is that right?
And it used to be g n is GDP.
Gross Domestic Product was about 1.6 2 billion in 1840 it was about 2.4 billion
in 1850 and the eve of the civil war in 1860 it was about 4.1 billion.
So GDP had more than tripled from 1840 1860 that shows us that there's an
industrial revolution already happening.
There were 9,000 railroad miles in 1850 in the United States.
There were 20 1018 60 the 1850s it was a great launching decade of
industrialization.
Now,
I'm going to give you a counter argument to that in just a minute,
but there are two economists named Claudia Golden and Frank Lewis who have
estimated estimated the actual price of the American civil war.
They put a price tag on it.
The cost of lives lost and have wounds that reduced productivity.
These are there variables in their factors.
Cost of lives lost in wounds that reduced productivity as well as property
destroyed and factoring in government expenditures to fight the war,
which were humongous state.
Some of them in a moment,
golden and Louis concluded that the overall cost of war was about six and a half
billion dollars to fight it and today's dollars,
that would be about 145 to $150 billion today to fight the four years of the
civil war.
This amount would have allowed the Fed.
This is,
this is golden and Lewis.
His argument,
by the way,
it's what economists can do with history if they so wish this amount would have
allowed the federal government that 145 250 billion,
it would have allowed the federal government to purchase and free all 4 million
slaves in 1860 at market prices,
give each family 40 acres and a mule and still laid ahead,
three and a half billion dollars leftover for reparations for former slaves.
That's golden and Lewis,
his argument I noticed,
I noticed it didn't get much of a rise out of you,
but
it's an interesting set of numbers.
History of course intruded during the war years,
the war,
retarded economic growth in some sectors,
but in the long run,
especially in northern cities and towns and especially with the mass
mobilization now stimulated by the federal government
or expand the economy like nothing ever had before so fast.
It just depended on where you lived.
But stop for just a moment.
Now with all these measures are numbers in your head.
If you can and just ask for a moment,
what can social history measure and what can it not measure?
It can measure very important things and I'm going to give you some more numbers
in a minute.
Okay.
Social history can measure demographic change.
It can measure death,
disease and casualty rates.
It can measure industrial production,
it can measure lots of civilian pursuits.
It can measure the number of women who enter the workforce.
It can measure government expenditures that can measure budgets.
It can even measure the basic social impact on a town I locality a community
and we now have a number of these wonderful micro histories of southern towns in
northern towns,
Midwest and so on during the war.
But how do you measure other social factors?
And this is one of those questions that makes history endlessly
necessary,
useful,
interesting tracks,
some of us fools to live with it forever.
How do you measure despair?
How do you measure loneliness?
How do you measure the dislocation and fear of widows?
How do you measure the suffering of soldiers from wounds and disease?
How do you measure the loss of a sense of home,
of dislocated worlds?
How do you measure nationalism?
Patriotism.
Sometimes we can find some measures of that in morale studies.
How do you measure the psychological damage of combat on the human psyche?
How do you measure the fracturing of marriages and relationships by war?
How do you measure homefront worry?
How do you measure the ways war test and changes,
values,
sentiments and morality itself?
How do you measure the social and moral consequences of killing people?
How do you measure femininity,
manhood,
patriarchy?
How do you measure what it meant to become free?
You don't,
but you do study it.
Now,
let me give you one other example or maybe to
social impact.
Let's go to one of those southern women.
She gets some mentions in foss book cause she wrote one of the great uh,
diaries and later memoirs that she then revise is not Mary chestnut and then the
ones so often quoted in the burns film series.
This one's name was Kate stone.
She wrote a great,
well she kept a diary that eventually was published as a book entitled Broken
Burn,
which was the name of her Louisiana,
uh,
cotton and sugar plantation.
It's an amazing book cause you can sort of follow the impact of this war on her
psyche by following her through the years and then after the war as well.
I'll pick her up right at the end.
The wars all but over.
And she records this in April,
1865 she has now moved over to Tyler,
Texas.
She has a refugee,
her slaves as the phrase went,
she's abandoned her plantation because the union armies took it in the red river
campaign.
She's lost half of her slaves.
She's lost two brothers in the war and a third one is come home stoned style.
He never speaks battle fatigue.
Shellshock posttraumatic stress.
Who knows?
They didn't have a name for it then,
but he never,
or silent brother was around.
Two of them are dead,
all are fearfully depressed.
She writes,
this is April 65 I cannot bear to hear them talk of defeat.
It seems a reproach to our gallon dead.
And then there's some sort of last gasp bravado and she hoped that she said the
thousands of grass grown mounds he'd done mountain side and in every valley of
our country would still rally the south to be free or die.
What bravado in a diary.
Then month later,
mid May,
1865 she opened the journal entry with a definition and then get any better than
this of the south immediate fate and especially the fate of women living in this
kind of now physical hardship in personal isolation.
Yeah.
She opened the entry with three underline words,
conquered submission.
Subjugation are the words that burn into my heart and yet I feel that we are
doomed to know them and all their bitterness.
She looked ahead,
should we and reflect about her class and her race
and then she said they,
the white planter class of the south would now become what she called slaves
quote.
Yes.
Slaves of the Yankee government.
She feared the quite specific what she called unendurable,
fate of blacks ruling over her submission to the union.
She went on how we hate that word,
confiscation,
Negro equality or a bloody on equal struggle last we know not how long.
Yeah.
And then in July of 65 rocking a baby in a chair in her arms and singing all the
songs she could remember,
she found,
she said,
quote the war song.
Second meeting.
The sound is like touching a new wound.
I cannot bear to think of it all.
I forget whenever I can.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's fascinating to follow Kate stone through time though.
She did all right
and weren't many men around which you finally met one.
This is incredible entry where she says she started going to social events and
one of them people were dancing and she couldn't bear to dance.
It just didn't seem right.
When she finally did,
she met a surviving confederate officer,
merit him and 1869 lived out of life,
had four kids and became the local head of the United daughters of the
confederacy in her town in Texas,
and lived until 1907
okay.
Kate stone did better than most,
but southern society went to war and paid an enormous price.
Of course.
Um,
civilians,
civilians were ultimately in some ways the strength behind the army's,
uh,
this war was to some extent lost on the home front for the south in particular.
Having said that,
you can say on the other side,
in some ways it was one on the home front in the north because of industrial
production,
because of sheer numbers and resources.
But it's worth from my memory here that the civil war happened to southerners
more than it happened to northerners.
Only a small portion of this war was actually fought on northern soil.
The confederacy failed ultimately to solve the problems of the home front.
Just think of a list and,
and,
and this is not to condemn them.
This was their challenge.
This is,
this is the risk they took.
This is what they risked was the session in 1861.
The problems of the home front,
they could not ultimately Soule in the midst of this massive enveloping thousand
mile front war surrounded button,
naval blockade money supply,
transportation.
Okay.
Agriculture,
agricultural production,
developing small industry,
creating a national bureaucracy that could be efficient,
maddening shortages of food stuffs,
clothing,
and about everything else it takes to keep armies in the field,
class,
frictions,
social disintegration.
And last but not least,
slavery,
what to do about slavery,
particularly once it comes under pressure in 1862 and then after the
emancipation proclamation,
which announces the purpose of the war now is to destroy slavery.
What does the confederacy do?
We will come back to that,
uh,
directly in terms of the confederate government policy on a kind of emancipation
late in the war in [inaudible] 64 and 65 the south did undergo some rapid
economic expansion,
remarkable economic expansion.
In fact,
if you read the sections on this and Jim Macpherson's battle cry of freedom,
his background,
he has some,
some glowing things to say about just how effective the south was in producing
cannon.
For example,
at the tredegar ironworks in Richmond,
they had 3000 slaves working in the largest industrial plant anywhere in the
southern states by 1863
okay.
Producing by and large their own weapons.
Yeah.
The naval blockade of the union.
A navy was not very effective at first,
but it was ultimately crippling by the latter part of the war.
The estimate is that about five out of six blockade runners,
these ships running the blockade got through,
um,
between 1861 and 62
but by 1864 and 65,
only about one of every two attempted blockade runners ever got through.
Okay.
There was widespread devastation of staple crop agriculture and those parts of
the south where the union armies moved in.
Charley Brewster just described those corn fields of central Virginia.
A union army near southern crops meant the crops were gone in 24 hours.
Yeah.
One of the world's greatest agricultural economies.
People began to go hungry by 1860,
late 63 and into 60 for bringing about major bread riots in cities like
Richmond,
Charleston,
South Carolina,
and other places with more than a half a million white men leaving agriculture
across the south.
It's seriously reduced productivity.
Okay.
And then a slavery began to dissolve.
Slowly but surely.
This of course disrupted production at least in about a third of the south
agricultural land.
Okay.
The occupation of the Louisiana,
for example,
early in the wars,
they're at least 62 brought the sugar industry to the edge of extinction and by
the wars in only about 15% of Louisiana,
1,300 sugars states.
We're operating at all the great sugar plantations of Louisiana.
We're in almost utter room by the end of the war,
especially after the Red River campaign of 1864 tobacco was in shambles is the
union armies move through Kentucky and Tennessee quite early in the war and rice
along the coast of South Carolina was devastated by union occupation as early as
62 and 63 and then there was the south decision,
Jefferson Davis's decision to engage in a cotton embargo that is,
they took cotton off the world market on the same,
more about this when we deal with questions of confederate defeat in terms of
their foreign policy,
but the policy by 1863 of the confederate government was to take cotton off the
world market,
trying to pull an OPEC trying to do with cotton with the OPEC countries in our
lifetime.
We've tried to do with oil,
pull it back,
make the world demanded and maybe make the Brits come in on your side.
It totally backfired and it was a total economic disaster for the south.
The production of cotton and the America and the confederate states went from
about 5 million bales in 1862 about one quarter million in 1865
no confederate fiscal policy was also a disaster,
not until 1863 did the Richmond government enact any kind of comprehensive tax
law.
Taxing was not very consistent from the federal level.
Well,
the way the confederacy was itself born.
Even then when they tried to pass a comprehensive tax law,
the confederacy derived in the in only about 7% of its revenues from actual
taxation.
The rest came from borrowing money from a bar abroad sale of bonds,
which is about 25% of their budgets.
Impressment of provisions from southerners themselves about 17% and in the end
about 50% of all money in the confederacy and its four years of existence was
printed paper money,
which it became inflated at ridiculous rates rapidly.
No,
so much more could be said here,
especially about this dissolving institution of slavery and how it affected the
south.
But let me spend the last five minutes on the north,
which is a very different story.
It's a more successful story.
It's a more progressive story in the literal sense,
and it is rooted in a particular kind of political vision that that Republican
Party brought to the federal government
before the civil war.
The federal government did little more than deliver the mail.
By and large.
Yes,
it's about all it did.
It collected modest tariffs and a conducted foreign powers,
but by the surrender at Appomattox,
a great deal had changed in four years.
Thousands.
We're poised to spread across the continent with the transcontinental railroad
businesses,
a big gun to operate on a national scale with massive new marketing plans and
full time marketing people.
Higher tariffs would bolster domestic manufacturing individuals experience the
nation state and it their allegiance as never before.
And array of new national taxes.
We're past the currency was nationalized.
The federal government,
distributed public lands,
chartered corporations,
and when in fourth,
black freedom with state or National Authority.
Okay.
And state's rights at least for the time being was Dell.
Nearly a death blow temporarily war enabled the Republicans to pass sweeping
visionary legislation born of a certain worldview.
And that worldview basically is captured.
And what the economist of the time,
political economists of the time,
like Matthew Kerry and others called harmony of interest.
This is the idea that in a capitalist economy you could bring labor and capital
into harmony if you kept labor free and the economy free all at the same time.
It was the belief that Labor and capital could be friends.
It also depended on an activist,
interventionists,
federal government,
and that is exactly what the Republican's created in part out of necessity of
the war and in part out of the fact that they actually believed in it and it's
going to bring about a great deal of the constitutional innovation and economic
experimentation.
Here's what they did
in finance,
in agriculture,
in taxes,
and building railroads,
and in emancipation at least those five major categories,
the Republican Party transformed the United States federal government.
They began by first selling war bonds.
The treasury needed money to fight the war,
the cost of the American civil war to fight it just for the union government by
1863 was approximately two and a half million dollars per day.
That's more than the federal government had spent in some decades before the
civil war.
Oh,
that's a financial revolution.
How are you going to do it?
How you're going to produce all this money?
They began selling bonds to banks and finance ears in 1862 about $500 million in
bonds were sold at 6% payable in five years.
Buy a bond,
support the war.
Okay.
The government then chose,
hired,
invited from the private sector,
the Philadelphia banker j Cook and listed him lead this federal bonds financing
program and he did lead it aggressively.
The whole idea here was economic nationalism to invest the citizen in the fate
of the union by making them pay for it.
And it was an 1862 that the federal government for the first time created the
greenback dollar,
the paper dollar,
which actually revolutionized American currency.
Financial markets went up and down during the war,
depending on battlefields,
success or failure.
But by 1863 they were financing a war.
Companies were making profits and the federal government could pay its bills.
It worked.
The total national debt of an annual two and a half billion was absorbed by the
general population and it was celebrated as what the Republican Party called a
people's triumph.
Okay,
now I'm
running into that wall of time.
God help me.
Let me leave you here with this.
Okay.
Now the north has enormous advantages of course,
in resources in population and industry and transportation and on and on and on,
and it had those New York bankers once they could convince them to stop being
anti union and pro-union.
But what came out of this was a revolutionary set of legislation that only
wartime could probably have produced.
The homestead act in the west,
the transcontinental railroad,
the moral act of 1862 which was the Land Grant College Act.
It's created agricultural colleges across the country by federal money.
In fact,
last week I gave a lecture at my Alma Mater and Michigan State and just outside
the lecture hall where I lectured was a copy of the original handwritten moral
act.
I know you don't care,
but I did
because Michigan Agricultural College was the first Land Grant College,
and they always reminded us of that every time,
every year,
freshman orientation,
and really frankly to understand,
and I'll leave you here to understand how northerners the Republican Party
Lincoln himself,
and at least the majority of those union troops came to support emancipation,
the freeing of black people by Federal Authority.
You need to see it in the context of all else that this Republican party was
doing through the federal government.
They were using government now as the engine of great social experimentation and
change.
Granted so much of it out of necessity,
some of it out of will.
I'm going to return to this story a little bit on Thursday as we move toward the
question of why the north winds this war.